hey martin what are you wearing
oh hi dina this is from an e-commerce
startup
their dev team is evaluating cloud run
for nine different types of workloads
i told them we'd find the answers for
them sounds great
stay tuned if you want to know more
[Music]
artisanship connects rural artisans with
consumers worldwide
my new hat came from ecuador their dev
team is excited about cloudron but they
aren't sure if it's a good fit for them
here i have a list of nine types of
workloads
dina could you tell me if cloud run
would be a good fit for those workloads
sure i'll do my best um what's the first
one
okay they want to build private
microservices that communicate with each
other asynchronously
cloud run would be a great fit it would
scale each service
up and down independently and
automatically
the services would communicate securely
with each other through cloud
pub sub and the service endpoints would
be secured by authentication
if they prefer services to explicitly
call
other services they should use cloud
tasks instead
of pub sub the calls are still robust
and asynchronous
but developers get more control over
things like retries
scheduling and rate limits all right
workload number two a public rest api
using https oh easy they can build a
rest service in cloud run which provides
an
https endpoint out of the box
they can also add their own custom
domain on this endpoint
all right workload number three
scheduled
maintenance jobs they can trigger their
cloud run services from cloud scheduler
cloud scheduler is also serverless and
it uses the standard
unix cron format all right
workload number four they get data feeds
from suppliers
in different formats the data needs to
be transformed and loaded into their
database
it's easy to build etl services in cloud
run and trigger them when files are
uploaded to cloud storage
another
web framework like flask or express on
cloud run
if their website runs on a software
package they may be able to use cloud
run
wordpress for example works on cloud run
but it requires extra configuration
the team should also check out app
engine which is a mature product for
building scalable web apps
many content management systems are also
available in the gcp marketplace
from the marketplace you can deploy
production grade solutions to compute
engine
with just a few clicks there are images
for wordpress
magento joomla drupal etc
all right workload number six
oh one of their microservices create
product images
using a binary library oh cloudrun can
do that
they would package the binary in a
docker container and call it from the
code
very well workload number seven they
also render video files
of some of their products these jobs can
take hours to run
well a cloud-run job can run for a
maximum of
60 minutes some long-running jobs can be
split into shorter jobs
and this may simplify the code and
enable parallel processing
but if their jobs can't be split up and
if they take more than 60 minutes
the team should use compute engine or
kubernetes engine
all right workload number eight
off-the-shelf software package for their
finances and warehouse management
any software or binary that can run in a
linux container and does not store data
on disk
can run in cloud run if their finance or
warehouse software
can't run in a linux container they can
run it on compute
engine instead all right workload number
nine the final one
this is a product recommendation engine
that will use machine
learning they should use recommendations
ai or
another product in google's ai platform
but
a cloud-run service can still call those
services to get recommendations
or even run custom machine learning
models well
those are all nine services you seem
awfully well prepared dina
did you peek at my list well
perhaps but only a little
we hope you enjoyed this episode